Hey guys, I just made a couple of exploding bottle targets for Slingshots, blow guns and pellet guns. So lets go have some fun!
That was a lot of dust and check out the damage total carnage.
So it's really cool is all that dust powder.
I made just came from a little carton of sidewalk chalk like these little egg ones. I got six for a buck.
[Water bottles blowing up and laughing]
Here's what's left of our two liter the cap here? Wow that's amazing. [oh]
Whoa! It bounced off.
Okay, I'll do it harder
That work check that out. It actually stayed on to the cab, but that thing is completely destroyed
Oh my goodness. That was amazing check out that mess
There's really nothing left of that bottle it split that right open, so let's add that to the other pile of garbage you got there
Yeah!!
Captions by TechNoDime
Subscribe